much like Elon Musk is joking around
about the diarrhea and
New York Times uh DeSantis is joking
around a bit about what he might do with
some of that land that Disney purports
to control because they don't control it
anymore and the state might have better
uses for it
if you look at this whole special
district Walt Disney Corporation
obviously owns a lot of it but the
district owns other lamb you know quite
frankly I wasn't even thinking about
that land this was not something that
was really important one way or another
we just wanted them to live under the
same rules pay the debt pay the taxes
all that stuff oh but come to think of
it now people are like well there's what
should we do with this land and so you
know it's like okay kids I mean people
have said you know maybe maybe have
another maybe create a state park maybe
try to do more amusement parks uh
someone even said like maybe you need
another state prison who knows I mean I
just think that the the possibilities
are are are are endless and so that is
now going to be analyzed to see what
would make make the most sense and um
and that wasn't necessarily even on our
on the radar it's kind of hilarious the
idea of a state prison like a Florida
State Penitentiary right next to
Disneyland it seems pretty effective if
you ask me but we shall see but the
point is once again guys if if you are
uh you know married to or have a brother
or a cousin or just a friend who is
confused by this who thinks that
DeSantis is being mean because Disney is
good Disney is Cinderella and Disney is
The Little Mermaid and they are good
guys you must have them understand all
he is doing is revoking special rights
and by the way when I talk about the
type of politician now the type of
conservative politician who will use
government when it is effective to use
it that's what everyone's looking for
what people are not looking for is the
type of politician who watches the
culture wars move on them right and
suddenly your kids are wondering about
their gender identity and all of these
things and it's being pushed through
cultural stuff that Disney is putting
out there and then you get answers like
Mike Pence from a couple weeks ago
remember that video from CNBC we showed
you where they asked Mike pencewell do
you think DeSantis is going a bit too
far by revoking Disney's special access
and and Mike Pence goes yes I'm a
limited government guy it's a bit much
if the government is not there to make
sure we have an even playing field then
there is no purpose of the government in
which case we should all be anarchists
and I think there's probably a growing
movement of that
foreign
[Music]